Thank you so much for joining us.
Um,
it's not everyday you get to interview and astronauts and an astrophysicist.
So I'm extremely thrilled.
I'm flattered to be here.
My name is Sarah.
I had up campus over in all street,
which is a space for entrepreneurs and I'm also the chair of women at.
And this event is one of the last events we're holding.
You know,
we hold talks a Google very often,
but our theme this year for International Women's Day was pressed for progress.
And you can interpret that in many ways.
We choose to think of it as influencing inclusive culture,
but also thinking about how we can live better lives.
And I think we'd all agree that space and the promise it has is a massive part
of that.
So I'm really thrilled to welcome our two wonderful guests.
Um,
they have really impressive biographies,
so forgive me for looking at my paper at the same time.
Um,
first things first at [inaudible],
a French doctor,
politician and former astronauts with the Sontra last year and I'll do two
special and the European Space Agency.
Um,
you studied,
uh,
medicine,
biology,
sports medicine,
aviation space,
medicine,
rheumatology,
um,
you've also got a phd in neuroscience,
incredible academic background.
You were a backup crew member for the 1993 near Altair mission and um,
in 2001 became the first European woman to visit the ISS following your career
as an astronaut,
you're into French politics as the minister for research and new technologies
and you're a commander of the Legion of honor.
So welcome flooding.
Um,
Ana Silvia Votto is an astrophysicist.
He's been working at the European Space Agency since 1991.
She's is currently chief diversity officer.
During her career at the essay,
she's held several positions including elaboration of high level strategy,
formulation of policies,
international relations,
strategic analysis,
relations with member states and networks with think tanks.
She has a specialization in astrophysics,
astrophysics,
and a further education at economics.
So welcome.
I said Aaliyah.
Um,
so [inaudible] like many of us in the audience I grew up dreaming of going into
space.
Um,
and you have this incredible academic record.
What made you,
you know,
after getting a phd in neuroscience,
what made you become an astronaut?
What was the original idea behind it?
Okay,
thanks very much.
I'm really happy to be with you today.
Uh,
it's not really the story from the Phd in neuroscience to become an astronaut.
I will begin with the flux at ty was 12 in July 69 for the first human landing
on the moon.
And it was really for me,
something incredible over to as this dream and accessible becoming your reality.
And at that time it was for me some things that fed my imagination.
I read a lot of documentaries,
science fiction books and uh,
everything.
Um,
as there is no,
as soon as cool,
it's not the curriculum,
the two you can until like that.
But I decided to become a medical doctor.
I'm a rheumatologist and I had just in the hospital where I was working in,
in package to discover a call,
an opportunity from the French agency to become an astronaut and taking part in
the century programs in the space station.
So for me,
it was clear it was for me and I tried it and ask her file and I did my,
put my candidature and goes through the selection and I've been selected.
It was in 85 and maybe some things that I can share more with the girls,
isn't it?
With boys.
I decided having been selected as an Sam Dittrich astronaut.
Okay.
I had a doctorate and I was an MD.
I did clinical research,
but I wanted to be sure that I will have all the right assets to be on the past
in between astronaut candidates to astronauts assigned to a mission.
So I decided to do a phd in order to work in a laboratory.
And to have really is,
it's a basic training as a scientist.
And so I would say that it's maybe a kind of a lack of confidence that
it was needed for me to have more than just was the first background in order to
ensure that I will get to all the assets to be,
to be on the past.
And it was wonderful to work in this laboratory for neuroscience because,
uh,
I choose the right laboratory in order to be in the team cooperating on space
program in micro gravity function in your body,
working with NASA,
with Jaxa Japanese agency or the Russian agency.
So that meant it was one element to be sure to be somewhere on the right path
after that.
And it was obvious for me that I had to try it.
And uh,
as I said after that,
a long time training because I had been separated in [inaudible] 85 and my first
flight was in 96 so long training in order to become not just the scientists but
also an engineer.
My first ride was as a scientist astronaut and my second plans as an boat
engine,
yours at men in charge of everything maintenance,
um,
of the,
the station and there was a vacancy.
So a long period of training and uh,
greet,
impatience to,
to visit day in August [inaudible] 96,
uh,
waiting for the surgery guy friends.
It's a beginning of the adventure and a really the adventures reality.
What's even more wonderful than the dream I had in mind and my imagination.
I'm very lucky.
I have to ask you more about about the reality.
I'm,
I mean I'm good at,
you know,
10 year training period to me is a staggering,
can you tell us more about like,
is there a particular moment that for you is simply unforgettable about your
first trip into space?
Just a moment that made you think,
wow,
this is worth this 10 year journey.
Whoa,
at this time.
But I would like also to say is that with the time as I explained Ali for 10
years in Russia because my two flights,
where is there a,
so your system and that mean there is a very wow moment during the flight,
the are so own moment with this period of life in star city in Russia.
I went there in [inaudible] 92 just at the beginning of the Russian period after
the Soviet Union and I saw oh to transformation and this was also cultural shock
and it was something really impressive.
And uh,
that means that we have wonderful and unexpected moments for the mission.
But I have a short mission,
a space mission,
but their research,
there was this incredible human adventure that I left for 10 years with my
colleagues with different culture,
diversity of gender,
diversity of backgrounds with the military pilots are as well as a scientist and
even,
uh,
tourist space stories at the time so that we have all the landscape where
there's a spectrum and for the flight,
what can I say,
uh,
as a rheumatologist and as a sport women,
I'm a gymnast.
I was really impressed with the new abilities I discovered being in free
floating,
but I can try to share a little ritual,
has senior pictures and movies about that.
And that's really exciting to see that we have some hidden,
I would say,
abilities that will be revealed in this new environment.
And this is this feeling of,
um,
freedom,
not completely comfortable at the very beginning because you have to build new
reference,
new frameworks.
And,
uh,
there is this,
a way to reorganize your sensory motor patterns,
but also to rebuild some cognitive references.
And,
uh,
for example,
the first time I looked through the window at this kind of visions that you have
on screen that men earth,
whereas above the customers or the sky.
So I we're not comfortable with that.
I had to do around the window in order to put everything on the right direction.
And the same to see Africa above Spain for example.
It was not comfortable for me also while to actively to community rotation in
order to,
to to be quite so this um,
ability,
uh,
potential for adaptation of hours,
sensory maturer sensors and the,
and the way this is really something incredible and Zinzi glance through the
window.
That's true too.
To have this chance to be in orbit and 400 kilometers from Earth as you know,
one orbit is 90 minutes.
So that means 16 times a day we have the flexibility to go through depending of
the kind of orbit,
if you're in there a bit with the Pacific for example,
it will be 50 minutes,
water,
water and the saint to see some of that.
So that's really,
yeah,
we are very privileged.
I think we are about 580.
Yeah.
Astronauts,
the small group,
just 10% female as,
wow.
I didn't realize it was the same person that came in about 60.
We can discuss that after of course,
10% applicants.
Candidates that means Oh,
interesting.
Yes.
Then 10%
10% perhaps similar as Renault's.
So that's the entry of the pipe and sees the reason they're fits it.
Yeah.
That's really interesting.
I really liked your point around we have abilities will be revealed in space.
Right.
That sounds wonderful.
Mystical.
Um,
and also,
you know,
from everything we've read about eight 10 picks,
diaries have helped a lot of us get a stronger picture of what it feels like
they are today.
How did the two journeys change your thinking when you came back to us?
How did you,
was anything that felt different?
I mean obviously we've all seen this story this week about Scott's Kalyan does
twin,
um,
you know,
we knew very little about that right now apart from the fact that 70% of his
jeans and are an identical identical twin.
But what in your thought processes,
what felt different when you came back?
I had short duration missions.
The first one was a 16 days mission and the second one in 10 days mission.
So nursing seem to see with Tim pig mission six months duration or a Scott
Kelly,
as you said,
one more one year,
uh,
mission.
And personally I've been surprised by the quick adaptation coming back.
So in a few sagon you have to use a gain your exterior reception and
proprioception in Europe,
uh,
Kim and sensors in their joints and also your vestibular characters in order to
cope with Patina less than two minutes.
You are okay.
Was that the first night?
It was a little bit strange because I had the feeling awake during the night
because my body was heavy weighting and all the objects that I had on my body
for monetary,
my physical state with the sensors,
everything was
floating in the room.
So I was always,
we can,
in order to put every senior on the,
on the same way though.
So there was a gap in between my personal feeling of coming back home and my
intellectual Roi.
Um,
cognitive feeling is that I was too in micro gravity,
but it's,
um,
so it's not at all the same for long duration.
Mission as you know,
is a resistor adaptation in micro gravity with the muscle relaxants that men and
muscular atrophy,
a demeanor realization for the bone structure.
So is that means it's a little bit a long process to,
to,
to go into the rehabilitation.
It's not a question of minutes to question few weeks and months in order to,
to be completely back to your style.
So I've seen already this paper about this difference in the gene sequences.
Uh,
and uh,
so it's,
it's a challenging question.
We know that there is radiation,
there is stress that can change something in their gene expression.
So we have to way to resolve it to,
to know more.
And what is difficult or,
so in this field of micro gravity,
for example,
I've always the question,
but what is the difference is a metabolism between the female astronauts
astronauts during a long duration flight.
Um,
as you know,
as a researchers in order to,
to get,
um,
uh,
certain,
I'm sure you need to have some cases and we have so few cases,
a female astronaut for long division pledge that it's difficult to say really
syncing and the same for this,
uh,
potential,
gene description.
We know that the reason normally after the flight,
but the fact of the Canada,
yeah,
we're lucky he's got,
it's been really bad.
I,
Sylvia,
you kind of,
um,
you know,
you've been working at the SAS,
it's notion it one,
obviously your background is in astrophysics.
My lucky number about how you came to space as well.
Was it a dream of yours when you were a child?
Um,
I know you've done so many roles in your time at the agency,
but how have you seen the agency evolve in that time?
Yes.
Oh,
I,
first of all,
I had to say when I was a teenager,
I was very tortured teenager,
very much into the poetry literature and they really needed something.
I wanted to study something that was able to take my center of gravity outside
myself.
It putting distance from myself.
I wanted to feel this sense of freedom,
even the sun.
So being nothing in an in an indifferent,
silent universe was,
was for me,
very empowering.
And I have to say,
I actually something that now in my job as diversity officer often say to girls,
there is a power of transformations by studying physics in particular,
uh,
that is forever.
And this is because you have a,
um,
uh,
we have,
you have to abandon your experience to understand and,
and you enter it in a different world.
Just give an example.
Uh,
you have 40 cents that the helium superfluid helium superfood is a magic think.
And if you go below a certain temperature,
he lose the third dimension.
It becomes flat.
So if you put in a glass,
you start climbing and goes,
I mean,
as a feel of a table.
Now this looks magic.
Uh,
it's something that you never experienced normally,
but it's through his physics.
And the same for,
for,
for what concerns space.
And I was actually studying general relativity and the fact that time fields
spit.
So change with speed and change with gravity.
So the time that we feel here is not,
doesn't go the same pace then on the space station and even further.
So all these things that looks again,
fiction are actually other laws of physic,
uh,
that are valuable.
And this put me in a dimension of,
or really feeling a sense of,
uh,
of a power as a human being,
a power of,
uh,
being,
the one that can ask questions and feel quarters.
Uh,
which by the way,
is the,
that also Steven Stephen King passed very strongly,
uh,
all through his life that,
Debbie,
do you ask questions is,
um,
is what makes the difference in this,
in this universe?
Um,
I've been with the European space white space space because again,
is it's a natural,
uh,
if you want to wear when you have this kind of,
of desire.
Actually desire is a,
is a,
is a very important award for me.
You're not desire Desiderio comes from the late in the [inaudible] s be far from
the stars.
So I act.
So I really believe that in each of us,
there is this tension to reach out to something bigger than us,
to something we want to,
we want to join,
we don't want to join back.
And,
uh,
it's a big driver and they felt this drive.
I needed this,
a spiritual demands,
the national,
you said,
sad.
And in listening to crowded this mystic dimension,
uh,
and so,
the Europeans facility also because of his international,
uh,
feature was really the perfect place to be.
I've also spent four years in Washington DC working a,
and the relations with Naza,
which added up another dimensional.
So not just the European model,
so to see from the other side.
And,
uh,
I,
and this is what I try now to pass also these,
uh,
the amazement,
the wondering of a,
of what we discover it we had the gravitational waves,
just this covert,
uh,
last year is big turning point where so many mysteries,
so still to solve.
And it's really a,
I mean,
this is the sense for me of,
uh,
of being,
mind and heart in,
in this
bust university.
Yeah,
I love it.
Um,
so we were really lucky last year in London.
We had an amazing exhibit at the Science Museum about the Russian race for Space
Star said he was a massive feature of it.
I don't know if anybody else went to it.
Um,
but yeah,
it was great.
Right.
Um,
and anybody who's my age challenger for me was a massive moment in my childhood.
I think the first time as a child that I was ever understood disappointment and
failure and you know,
that that could have immediate pain.
Think a lot of kids followed that very closely.
Um,
and it kind of struck me at the Russian exhibit that that seemed like such a
golden age in terms of space.
And I'd love to get your thoughts on,
you know,
obviously with the Scott Kelly's story in the last year we've seen Tim Peake can
make the most of media.
Um,
but it feels like a very different era in terms of space and are designed to
explore space.
Do you think that's fair?
Like what do you think about the,
the shifting politics of space over time?
You can
generally,
as should is a
perception.
Today we have a globally.
So on the institutional side,
we have modern 70 billions that are funded,
uh,
spent in a space activity,
see space activities.
We have,
uh,
the babble of actors so well beyond the usual suspects.
So now we have about 75,
uh,
countries that spanned invest more than 10 million in space.
Uh,
so it's really a large bank and in a way you see that it's not just the
economic,
the economic interest because actually for this 70 millions spent,
you have a downstream activity that is a factor of five out of that.
But there is this a,
again,
this tension,
this desire of prestige in a way.
I think that apart from sports that really makes achievements,
uh,
known to everyone,
to humanity is only space activities going really give this status and this
statement.
And of course the results.
So the fact that the space infrastructure is,
uh,
is something that now is part of our daily life.
Uh,
and you know,
also in terms of exploration,
if you take us,
Japan,
Russia,
Europe,
South Korea,
India,
China,
uh,
in a five year style we have about 15 missions,
mono oriented,
similar number,
Matt,
uh,
driven.
And then the asterisk there,
the planets.
So there is a,
there is a big activities.
The problem is the,
of course,
what was the time being really pioneering.
But there is still elements of pioneer rank coming in particular now also from
the private sector.
So I think the dynamic is really is really,
there is not a,
it's not a loss interest.
And also astronauts,
we see us for notes,
the twitters and the media coverage.
Yeah.
Yes,
for sure.
And the,
you have been in a right place to see the way Tim Peake communicate with a
Instagram,
Twitter and a,
it's really interesting to share immediately is this,
uh,
adventure.
Uh,
yes,
that's true.
That there is a new era for,
for space.
And uh,
you evoked also those are private companies that are involved now and are
challenging our way to,
to think and to organize.
And I have a dream.
And this,
uh,
the concept I'm working on,
in the European Space Agency,
this concept to about specific oration,
human space exploration to enlarge this concept of exploration to the one of
expansion of our humanity on a no,
the surveys,
the moon surface and um,
working on a moon village concept set,
male building a permanent infrastructure with a robotic and then permanent
infrastructure where we will live and work in a bit.
And that means for me,
it's an interesting concept because we need to think in germs of new landscape
out of the books,
out of the atmosphere,
new partners on the Internet side,
you said the international space station with five partners and we will have a
Chinese speciation in a few months from now,
but with different interests in different way to cooperate.
And we have to think this
village that men live together for the future of humanity in a,
in a new environment with private interest mining for example,
to exploit some resources,
tourism,
um,
cultural,
uh,
and industries and energy,
building a new materials,
a lot of economic expansion.
Also in term of economics and economic in the surrounding of the earth economy,
et cetera and so low earth orbit economy,
the space station for example,
we decided to um,
to be in this exploitation of the space station with his partners and the Public
Institution until 2024 maybe 2028 and then to begin to think in terms of
commercial expectation of the low earth orbit,
but whoever's,
so to think in terms of this expansion and expanding the economical sphere,
I would say a four earth.
So that's been,
that's really an interesting concept in order to racing ever sing in terms of
governments,
interfaces,
partners,
that's it will be powered kind of activities that would be there.
The scientific one on the far side,
those a moon or a lot of the science as we can do as the moon and from the moon,
a technological developments,
Roberta advanced robotics and interaction with her and this is very exciting to
try to reconsider in order to,
to be actively involved in changes and not just passive too.
Yes,
that's even receiving the tenders by the new actors and you are going to make
that.
So yeah.
So I think we need such visions in order to be really active and to design the
future.
We wish.
Yeah,
I like that very much.
What are the,
um,
what are the timelines?
Is something like [inaudible] village?
I mean,
I think,
um,
many of us have long burning cited by the,
the idea of how to go into space as a tourist,
but I love the idea of building a new world,
kind of testing out an infrastructure that is nation less in some ways on the
moon.
What would be,
what kind of timelines for a project like that?
And I'm guessing this kind of thing,
it's very long term I would say begins already because there is some,
uh,
some,
probes around,
uh,
the moons.
There will be soon a new probes from the Chinese side on the far side of the
moon and Mars sample return and the Indian one and the Japanese one.
So that been them robotic elements in order to make some maps,
uh,
defining your,
so where are some resources that we will have to use because if you are building
something and the surface of the moon,
you will try to do with the in situ resource utilization.
So that means we have to to make the map of it disabilities.
So this is already the way for the first crew.
Uh,
I would say that's a,
if really we decided to go in 2030,
for me it's something that can be achievable.
We have been already,
uh,
with six mission say Apollo period on the,
on the moon.
So for sure the techniques that jammed and as a result lots of a new element to,
to secure in order to it.
And there is also two to secure this sustainability because I'm speaking not so
much in term of exploration with short period of visits,
but living and working in the surface and sets men sustainability as well as the
economic,
our sustainability,
sustainability for our living in there.
But for the first group and I hope a crew with a female astronaut and not just
men restaurant because there was 12 men on the moon,
uh,
means there's 20 survey twenties.
Yeah,
it can be something achievable.
How does,
um,
I'm going to pick up back up on this piece around no woman on the,
but I want to start with,
you know,
the two of them as well known figures right now and the race to space Richard
Branson,
Elon Musk.
How does public and private interrelate in this world?
I mean,
do public figures like that,
setting these very audacious goals,
does that help this mission of if the goal is to raise perception and
excitement,
trans space for the next generation of kids to become astronauts?
Sure.
I have to say that actually what you bring also from what [inaudible] was saying
is that we are in a moment of many paradigm shifts.
So we have four server actually this move from being explorers to start thinking
on being also settlers,
which is,
which is something new.
I mean was not this the,
the,
the project at the time with just going that and come back.
So there is,
there are two venues that opened up,
uh,
at the same time,
the paradigm shifts actually to have this new,
what we call the [inaudible] nurse coming in.
Uh,
and the entrepreneurs coming in actually driven by two,
two things on one side.
Of course,
the gold rush as it's called in the,
in the US,
because you have unchartered territories to the score at the same time.
I mean,
there is a,
uh,
infrastructure,
that,
uh,
I mean is needed for the booming economy or the digital ago for the booming
market or the digital economy.
So is there,
is this,
uh,
attraction from,
from the business,
but also the fact that in a way you,
you,
you can see a race between the billionaires,
uh,
and,
and even with their project,
you know,
Elon Musk with this project of colonizing a,
the solar system with,
uh,
with humanities is one of the most daring and ambitions adventure that in a way
we,
we had put on the table.
And of course,
um,
and the same,
the project for Branson,
a from,
uh,
from Basil's.
So,
so there is really now a,
sometimes in a provocative way I say that what was before the race between
nation now is race between [inaudible] this,
uh,
this,
billionaires,
but all this is a,
is good for space because it changed.
They have,
okay,
they have of course the weight to,
uh,
to challenge the institution and to make,
it's changing.
Uh,
the U has with the under Obama was preparing for this,
uh,
for the,
for the condition of having this expansion of the economic sphere to low earth
orbit and entering in on the commercial sectors.
So it has brought to the dynamic that is a,
is,
is a very interesting dynamic and,
and very inspiring dynamic in particular for the new generations that are very
much,
uh,
looking for,
with a perspective,
not on the 60,
but with the purse over the youth award of the virtual reality.
Really to get into this kind of adventure.
Uh,
you know,
the program
from mask,
uh,
is a,
is,
is very ambitious.
He wants to build sworn this a B Fr,
you know what it is.
And it was to be a part sample.
Is Bfi
a
big falcon?
And they kept track of it.
Okay.
Exactly.
And actually has justice many similar space,
right?
So he has just announced that he plans to after,
I mean the,
the successful flight of [inaudible] nine,
the heavy lift is planning to have the Bfr by 2019 and the 2019.
And this should be able to be the vacant because when we talk about exploration,
you have always to to think about how you get there.
And so what makes also his plants saturable is that it first starts from how do
we go there and then what we do.
And the same also,
I mean for,
and that's one.
So maybe something,
uh,
I'm convinced this is a private landscape is changing,
challenging and it's very useful for transforming.
But we have also,
I think on the public side and institutional side to keep some safe rules.
I would say for example,
for the Moon Village,
uh,
we will have to think in terms of preservation of some things that she's a bad
came wandering many tape mode and the way to work with scientists wanting to do
some kind of experiment and all the other sides and mining industries.
So we will have to,
to cope and to,
to,
to make the Armani and synergy in between for example.
And then for Mars exploration.
I have been in space,
I know and we discussed the fact that the recent changes in genes first got
Kelly.
So we know that there is physiological constraints.
That's a raise,
uh,
radiation,
difficulties,
psychological speaking about Mars mission and the twins.
For me It's not a chore clears that we will be ready to go to Mars in 10 or 20
years from now.
We need to keep,
um,
with the understanding that we have for the time being of there.
And it's not just a question to access somewhere when we are speaking about
Schuman specified,
but access,
preserving,
leaving,
keeping safe and coming back for the time being never,
yeah,
we had a sample return for Mars.
That means that we know how to go there,
but we don't know how to come back.
And that means for me.
So I want to keep cool,
we say for this kind of a Mars zero with their return mission,
I think ethically and industry to institutionally,
I cannot be in favor of this kind of thing.
So that's where I put her.
So this,
this uh,
ability to the um,
public policies to build.
So keeping some safe paradigm and think about the European Space Agency.
We are 22 member states coming from all over Europe and Europe is a different,
uh,
I mean,
Eh,
you have,
we have more than 40 languages.
Talk About Amanda says,
uh,
we have also Canada as a company thing state.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
we have,
I mean,
this international aspect,
it's really future of us and,
uh,
it's,
it's another future is the,
is the fact that we have multi year funding.
So once we agree on something,
we,
it's very difficult.
We go back.
So we are,
we're a very interesting international partner also for this aspect of,
of,
uh,
in a way,
the fact that we don't change,
we have no reason to change in plants every year,
but we have been able,
uh,
putting all these talents together to do things that a single a nation cannot
afford,
that we have been able to a few or to go to land a Robo on a spinning car mat at
400 million kilometers for here from here.
Uh,
and
Jose,
there was an automation that just dropped a feeler on the surface of the
comments.
This was amazing.
This was a,
it would say almost our men on the moon at the time because this was completely,
uh,
an achievement that was a completely new,
and was interesting was the fact that we want there to understand how water come
came on earth.
And we found water on,
uh,
on the comment on true ray because too much,
too long name.
Uh,
but this water cannot be the water that we have or not and can never become.
So these are little pieces of uh,
uh,
it's,
it's very,
uh,
let's see.
Heavy water,
so cannot become the Woodrow versions,
but all these moments that brings together the sense of belonging and the fact
that while joining forces,
you cannot choose something is also the straw.
And cooperating with international tartar is the strength on this institutional
partners.
Uh,
and how really you get the citizens,
uh,
feeling the sense of achieving to whether something while on the private
sector's the drivers are different.
So it's a,
there is an element of,
you know,
as Silicon Valley Classic Tech Entrepreneur going into this field because a lot
of their,
you know,
a lot of the artists like valley and be fast and break things.
And that's not something you can really do with space.
Right.
It gets a lot more complicated.
Um,
so I've got a couple more questions and I'm going to hand it over to the
audience for your questions if that's okay.
And I'd love to get back to Vf,
ours and 10% of astronauts being women.
Uh,
you know,
obviously if this whole mission is about discovering new worlds and inventing
new ways of living,
um,
and exploring the I known,
it's really important that we represent the world itself really well in that,
in that mission.
Um,
obviously I sell a unit chief diversity officer and you spoke earlier today
about the pipeline challenge of not enough women applying to become astronauts.
I think first things first,
I'd love to ask you,
um,
for those in the audience who might be thinking,
oh,
I should become an astronaut.
What do you need to apply to become an astronaut?
I know that's a silly question.
I think probably is a bit too late for me,
but maybe,
um,
uh,
as I said before,
there is very different profiles.
You have a pyros engineering or aerospace or,
uh,
researchers in different fields.
I think that the main point is to,
to look for other time or for selection.
I cannot say today when will be the next election of the European Space Agency.
Last one was in 2008.
But I'm sure that there will be another one,
um,
zones.
That's mainly what you said.
It's the desire to have them then the commitments to enter in it.
So what,
uh,
um,
then patients
best server runs and determination because the a long time to to go through um,
um,
to um,
the chance healthy terms too,
too bad because for a rounds of,
for example,
the last election of the Europeans were sentence,
I think there was 8,000 candidates we send personal female candidate and a six
has been selected.
I'm convinced that there are more than six talented persons to bear.
So that means there is a part of John's and we have to organize everything,
know to,
to build this a chance.
But what's the,
uh,
wanted to underline with um,
discussion with Earth Eylea about does this,
um,
at directiveness or deficit of attractiveness for science engineering carriers.
I think we have really to think in terms of,
uh,
science and technology years are the two pillars.
In order to cope with the big challenges,
that's where we have in the 21st century.
And we will have and to,
to find some new solution.
But if we try to speak just about the scientific approach,
the hard science,
the regular,
it's maybe not so attractive for
male and female,
I would say,
but popping up because we need to have an,
a feeling of,
uh,
what we will give entering,
engaging in a,
in some way that's been good.
The tuna context in the sons for the life as the twin,
we have to take the humanities back in.
Science,
engineering and digital culture can be a good link in between this.
So humanities,
technology,
computing,
science,
butter.
So responsibility about where are we going?
Human inside.
Okay.
So we have to think in terms of our responsibility.
We have to develop something.
So,
so for me,
what is really neat now speaking about science,
technology,
engineering,
mathematics,
you're starting to put that in culture and coming back with humanities are I
think in the [inaudible] curriculum,
it's maybe easier to have this in France for example,
I don't know in Italy,
in France as you choose to Shanti Fail Cheese,
oh,
chose the Eh,
you managers I would say.
And it's difficult to,
to,
to put up and I think it's one of the,
um,
problem in our curriculum.
So for me with the time,
I think that's more and more important to ever,
so you managers thinking philosophies survey and as a registered say it long
time ago,
he says that there is three pillars,
epistemic,
epistemic science research techniques.
That means technology,
engineering and fantasies and furnaces.
That's I would say is,
um,
wisdom to act.
And I'm sure you had to wear this paper from MUSC.
Prensky about digital wisdom that we have are so in this world of the digital
culture,
it is yours to keep in mind is kinesis and with them and pharmacists will not
come strictly from hard sciences and engineering.
How are you thinking about with that in mind,
how you're thinking about that pipeline and kind of getting more girls and women
into the application process?
Um,
and I think there is something around,
often,
certainly in the startup world we focus on hard tech roles.
Whereas I would argue there are many wells make companies successful in all
companies including this one.
How are you thinking about getting more gossip and Ntsa in general checking the
astronauts?
We have,
uh,
we have a paradox in Europe where we have now in almost all countries,
the girls are number both in terms of the,
I mean graduation so that we have more girls graduating.
However,
the science field is still a boys' club.
Uh,
we say we used to say doctors come from Venus and engineer from Mars.
You see the latest,
uh,
there is really a much higher repetition for boys to get into stem.
So Science,
technology,
engineering and maths than for birds and in the digital awards is even much
worse.
You are really a level today.
Most of Wikipedia is written by man and a,
and there are very few women in digital worlds.
And that's the case today.
But that we,
this is our technical office to
exactly,
but it is a,
there is,
we know today from,
I mean there are many things that influence this and one of the things he's also
related to stereotypes and the way or to the context bring six petition or with
respect to the career.
So girls and boys.
So we are engaging with the old space sector actors who industries engaging a to
fight the stereotypes.
But uh,
and uh,
really to be more vocal about this power of transformation then space can
brings.
But as a,
as a Claudia was saying,
we are trying also to change the narrative with respect to the stand,
uh,
in particular engineering,
and technology because,
um,
we are facing a big revolution.
We know the future of work means that would be a polarization of skills.
So you will,
you will need skills,
uh,
that relates to persuasion,
amputee,
multiple thinking.
And I usually get the provocation thing that it looked that for Robo will be
easier to replace men than women.
We are.
And that there is a theory of how the stereotypes,
but we want to tell the story of the stem of the future,
not the stammer to the Er because engineering today's some tank but through the
digital,
uh,
the,
I mean the coming of the digitalization or robotic sound sound and the new
challenges or had,
so we these,
that the expiration,
the settlers climate change,
we need a completely new set of,
uh,
of jobs that the,
what we called the bridgers,
the orchestrators,
the,
and these are the jobs in stamp for tomorrow and which are also include this
aspect of humanities.
So not just that thing,
but it's a bt to think at large and we promoting this,
uh,
we,
we want really to get different narrative about what these jobs are as from is
the perception today that these careers are,
so we really are investing now in this,
uh,
in this branding in a way.
And coming back to the profession of astronauts,
I would say that's typically a profession where you need to have abilities to go
in different fields.
I say that there is different but grown at the beginning.
But then you become an engineer or you
become a partner in a crew,
you became a diplomat and uh,
um,
and you think about humanity when looking through the window and the boat's
planet.
I love it.
Final question then I'm going to hand over to all of you.
Um,
I always like to end with a fill in the blank question where I'm going to ask
you something and I'd love a very short answer.
Please.
Um,
space is no limits is a perspective.
Hmm.
Um,
a book that I always recommend is brief history of time.
Oh,
the pudgy past or something.
So petty and I love it.
I love that book.
Um,
the best advice I ever got was never take a no for an answer.
Uh,
excuse me.
The best advice I ever got was,
uh,
maybe not advice,
but,
uh,
when is the last time when you did something for the first time?
Said to me sort of with thinking new and finally,
um,
googless can help the European space station by
for me is by stretching the imagination or what can become possible.
Yup.
Um,
come in.
Next is the moon village,
but evolving involving everyone,
young generation.
What is,
I don't know.
And sayings,
a virtual reality.
Um,
oh,
we can help me in,
in getting involving the same generation in it.
I love it.
What's the URL for the Moon village by the way?
Is there a micro site we can look at with information?
Well,
just beginning in the settings.
That's it.
Yes.
Would it be so wonderful?
Yeah.
Audience.
What would you like to ask
one hand in front row.
Oh,
I don't think we've got Mike friends too because we are recording
please.
Huh?
Hi,
Debra Patel is Google.
I hope so.
I hope you liked the star city for your time there.
So I was both the astronauts and the scientists.
Where do you stand on the question of do human actually need to go?
It's space.
Is there a space is a place for human space exploration that will just need to
go with rope?
Put sentence,
uh,
telescopes.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're just going along the way.
Okay.
No,
uh,
I'm sure that your share the fact that a human will go further and explore and
it's not the same when you have a,
I would say,
uh,
astro note telling this feeling of,
Bertie freedom in micro of the low through the window.
And uh,
so this embodiment,
uh,
encounters,
as a dream that you have and humanity will go further,
further and explore.
But for me it's not a Turrell and competition in between the automatic universe
sciences and uh,
this human desire to,
to,
to go further.
And I think he's a really complimentary,
I want one speaking about,
for example,
a movie latencies
shift,
uh,
in between exploration and expansion for humanity going on another planet and
the settlers as well as a explorers.
It's for me or so a way to have an off beat.
I would say glancing gays,
you know,
the,
to
come back to her with a new solution because we will ask new problems in this
hostile environment.
So it's,
for me,
that's that something that is completely,
completely synergistic I would say.
And I will not put to priority.
And because science is a science with all the dimension and a,
as I said,
the not just a dimension of new knowledge but also new opportunities and I think
this human spaceflight sort.
So,
um,
opportunities that will open new or raisins.
Yeah.
Um,
this question is for cloudy.
you mentioned that looking through the window is all about perspective and I was
wondering if maybe you could share the kind of perspective that that gave you.
Is there a reason I was not just thinking in terms of human space flight.
When I say perspective for me for example,
uh,
one of the most powerful conquest of the space race and the beginning and uh,
57 who is the first Sputnik in a,
in space is,
uh,
also this ability to have a new Gazans the planet for example,
and the ecological feeling consciousness.
I think it's coming from that point.
So this is for me or soon aspect of new perspective in order to reconsider a
earth new perspective because it's open opportunities and new developments and a
no let for humanity.
So that's also a new perspective.
And,
uh,
strictly speaking,
looking through the window.
So you see,
uh,
the planet like that youth is the beauty of this planet.
You have this overview effect.
So it was a beauty of the planet,
Bertrand Russell,
the black customers.
This mister is,
is um,
uh,
um,
you put one smart humanity and human responsibility.
Visa VI is this a this Bennet and um,
it's meant to the very thin layer of atmosphere that means the fragility.
It's a also perspective because when you are on earth,
okay,
you got some media saying be careful with this is this,
uh,
hair really it's even much more than a perspective is that's a fact.
You have it.
Yeah.
On that.
Hello?
I just went to say,
I'm so happy that you're here because when I was,
uh,
when I was a kid,
I saw you on TV and I was amazed that you would do that,
um,
and said this is great.
Um,
you talked about responsibility and um,
perspective.
I'm just wondering,
uh,
food up Moon Project for example,
Moon village.
Um,
what do you think the,
the actual objective things that we should be doing to protect,
protect a moon.
And um,
we were talking,
you said that Ms. Spears very thin when we're here we don't really care so much
or not as much as we should.
What should we put in place to protect where we are exploring where we may be
settling?
Uh,
that's what's for me very interesting in this concept of the molecular too
because we will have to have this kind of question.
Uh,
Undertale Warren's a different step of the buildings,
the concept four for shores,
there is a technological,
I would say building blocks that we have to,
to to put in the table in order to have the right protection for the habitat for
our,
the,
the way to extract oxygen from the
ice ones,
a pull of the moon.
So this is one part.
Then if we really considered the concept as working with private companies was
economical interest and Sundays I said we would have to seek in terms of the
right cooperation harmoni in between the interest,
then we would have to cope with what I said already is,
is a treaty and the you need to nation defining the [inaudible] books as,
as um,
as the moon as a [inaudible] insights is mean to,
to preserve something as a [inaudible] element.
They manage it.
So we let to,
to keep that in mind.
Uh,
for sure we will have to define also those are the rules I would say for them.
Um,
international governments since different partners because,
uh,
mainly cooperation in a global project,
which are so competition in,
in,
in dealing with some elements and um,
the way to organize their life of say inhabitants of the is,
is the mornings for phase.
So is there is a lot of thing to elaborate.
Think about Hannah.
I would like that to be taken really seriously,
progressively.
Um,
uh,
the technical element is just one part of the project,
but all the suspect men's needs are so that we have with us,
the jury's dizzy.
Sociology's the philosophers,
um,
architects because that's a complex architecture to organize.
So that's why it's a lot of potential in thinking in that terms.
And I said,
uh,
we have the chance to,
to think out of the atmosphere and not just out of the books.
So
I love it.
I think that was one,
oh,
we've just got one over there.
Okay.
I just wanted to pick up a little bit more on what Sarah mentioned a little bit
earlier,
our loan about your sense of self.
I'm both of you talked about sense of self and a really interesting way you
mentioned that you,
I wanted to change your center of gravity from,
from a very insular person to something.
Uh,
yeah.
More expansive.
And when Sarah mentioned any changes that each felt when you came home from
space,
you spoke in a very,
uh,
anatomical way about changes you'd felt in your body.
And I guess I wanted to ask a question of,
has a life I'm in space and working in this new world changed your sense of
self?
Do you know,
perhaps relate more strongly to something greater then two,
you are as a person,
have you felt that you've changed your relationship with yourself as a result of
this,
uh,
career path that you've taken?
Well,
it's
difficult to say because there was different elements coming in.
Um,
the first is,
um,
relation with you with the hood big portal and the look and the questions that
loves it make sense.
This is the way to,
to communicate,
to,
to interfere,
um,
as this is the first element of [inaudible] I had the chance to have different
life as it has been said.
I've been a medical doctor,
I've been an astronaut,
I've been a minister.
I've been the head of a public establishment.
I was closely cooperating with the Science Museum.
I was in charge of buddy [inaudible] in France.
I'm deeply involved in the innovation.
I've been involved for three years with theologist about,
uh,
digital challenges with the humanity.
So that's been age different,
uh,
ecosystem different too.
Like for sure it's um,
something that is um,
billing you and what's interesting in life also,
you honor the same at the beginning and the end,
um,
with the um,
opportunities,
meetings person you will and cantor.
So,
um,
I have no really curious to say is that just space space as being for me for
sure a multiplier of this life and the opportunities if I,
if I can say for me is,
is against science and space.
Uh,
and,
and this,
the courage that you get out of this adventure,
a sense,
different sense of belonging.
First of all,
the international side with the same mean I am an Italian.
Uh,
this is also you ask your questions,
but on this global side,
you know,
there is,
there is a sentence that allow from Thomas Elliot which say is poof rock.
I don't know if you'll know this poem where you say,
do I dare to disturb the universe?
And for me,
this is really how myself,
my own self change it through this adventure,
meaning this sense of daring because actually no one cares about.
If you are not doing something well,
if you do something then it can be a difference.
And a,
and again this,
uh,
this sense of a belonging to something big,
much bigger than you and the fact that you are nice,
don't give me this,
uh,
I would say this unconcerned.
So these,
uh,
sometimes it's courage not to bother about what the other thing and not too bad.
And this is an important message if we want to relate also to girls and women
because we know that actually there is an anxiety that comes up from uh,
with respect to scientific subject mathematics and,
and there is a very nice story from Brian Greene,
which is a very famous astrophysicist and a erodes the elegant universe and
explaining and actually wondering why in,
in women who have this form of a,
you don't want to look stupid,
you don't want to ask question and it has the side that it goes to a primary
school,
kids,
a five,
six year olds and ask everyone to do something.
And there is this little girl but he focus,
drawing,
drawing.
So he approached her and say,
what are you drawing?
And she says,
I'm drawing the fissile God,
the fizzle God,
but no one knows the face of God.
Oh,
in a minute they will,
uh,
this sense of exactly going back to the sense of I don't care what the other
think.
I,
Eh,
it's a moment I have to go and this will will bring so much to me and should not
be stopped.
I think we have one question that,
and then I think we'll have to do these two.
And I'm finishing my,
Fred,
I think we have one over here.
Hopefully it can be quick.
And so my daughter wants to be the first woman on the moon because she's six.
And she says,
well,
why shouldn't I be?
Um,
she's the face of God.
What's the one thing that you think I can do to support her in that?
Yeah.
Okay.
First of all,
uh,
and,
and then I leave clinic to answer.
I also have a girl,
now she's a,
she is older than this,
Matt.
Um,
you know,
we know from studies that girls don't go,
don't apply to positions because they,
if they don't match with the 100 requirements,
they don't go wild man.
Look on the first row,
the license,
no one's,
this is the sense actually it's a perfect question.
Uh,
after what I said,
there should be a pleasure in PR in,
in going forward.
There should be a pleasure in daring at something that you don't in any way.
This court,
even if it's goes to a failure.
So the sense of failures,
which it should change,
you know that one the,
when I was in the,
in the u s actually after the Columbia accident,
the motto was from NASA was failure is not an option today.
The motto of Naza is fail early,
fail smart.
So the value of failing,
which it doesn't mean that you have lost you are not losing you is just
something that will brings new things and useless ranked.
And if you go through this sense of failure as being part of the path,
I'm sure she will be.
She will be more daring and she will get ready to take this bold steps without
feeling.
When I say don't take no for an answer without thinking,
ah,
this is not,
I'm sure there will be thousands of why me example of cruddy in this sense is,
is a,
is very important.
But the thing is they should be 1000,
so could mean me.
Uh,
and so work on this sense of,
of what is success and what is failing.
Mlr bubble am a capable,
which for girls is very strong.
Sometimes they,
they want to be lovable
and the,
and then you pass the message.
You are lovable if you're capable.
So be sure that these are different things and,
and,
and then you get the strength to,
to go from that.
But just,
I would add that it's what's important for me is more the journey,
I would say,
of discovery than the goal and the objective.
That's important too,
to have a goal.
And if you can,
uh,
keep the dream alive for her,
that's perfect.
There's explaining that through Howard is the journey that will be pleasure
discovery with a curiosity and she will gain and gain and gain a lot.
Um,
if the goal is really very,
very ambitious,
we cannot from eyes to,
to get to the goal.
But the journey is a wonderful path.
And our final question,
hello pressure.
Um,
you mentioned that you know,
space is not like,
Hey,
I want to go to space next week.
So you know,
less collect plants
and being an astronaut is,
you know,
perhaps at that k or multi decade kind of ambition.
So throughout kind of these very long journeys,
how do you kind of pick yourself up when you go,
oh my God,
I just,
you know,
this week it wasn't as good as last week.
And how do you pick yourself up over very,
very long time period?
What's say is that,
uh,
I had a lot of things,
new things.
That's why I explained that as a journey.
So I was a medical doctor.
I'm gauging this phd.
So that's mean discovering the,
working in a laboratory and then discovering the way to cooperate with different
partners.
And then arriving in star city,
as I said at the very beginning of the shift in between the Soviet Union.
So discovering this military environment and the blackboard there was a black,
uh,
in order to,
to get my first lesson in Russian,
in order to make us a design of a certain element.
And then a few years after that coming here,
they are American for example,
with the shuttle Mir poke harm suicides mean,
uh,
keeping
interested with there's this mixed culture.
I said also that training with uh,
um,
space tourists during,
so
every time there was something new to discover,
to learn.
That's why the journey is something you're really fantastic.
This is a adventure for sure.
I was eager to be on the day of the luncheon,
the launchpad in a,
in Baikonur,
but,
uh,
really enjoyed
16 years of career and I enjoyed after that just to go in life and just sort of
life and so forth when I have now and,
uh,
the sets and I wish we had time to ask you about the mall,
particularly the political,
I'm particularly curious about that,
I think.
Um,
um,
thank you so much.
Both of you.
This is maybe on the political field
just in the first part as a medical lecturer because I wa was bright in my
studios,
so no problem.
Come in and give up.
And with the astronaut,
uh,
also it was relatively easy.
I would,
I would say for me that's interesting in a
bit with political I discover and thing is that,
uh,
I was convinced before entering in politics is that when there is a will,
there is a wage and I discovered not her way.
Um,
thank you both so much for joining us.
It's been amazing.